how many saiyans does it take to change
a light bulb one but it'll take him 17
episodes to do it
goku begins removing the light bulb from
the box
next time on dragon ball z
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we aspire to reach frieza levels
of dialogue
what's the deal is your phone call over
good thing they reached you before i
disconnected your number
poetry it's simply poetry now it's been
a long time since we last covered dragon
ball
in fact how to do a kamehameha wave was
one of the first uploads on this channel
unless of course you include that one
video where i talked about the power
level of ultra instinct shaggy remember
when that was a meme for a hot minute
but
man people love dragon ball it played a
major hand in popularizing anime in the
west it gave cartoon network some of the
highest ratings they'd ever seen and
according to the npd
group dragon ball z is the number one
selling anime brand of
all time i mean sure you may have gotten
some odd glances from your parents when
they saw you watch trunks scream at
frieza for 12
seconds straight in slow motion
one hour later
but at its heart it's really a show all
about overcoming obstacles in the face
of overwhelming adversity
and screaming at each other's faces for
prolonged periods of time but buried
amongst the dragon ball franchises 600
plus episodes
19 movies and one vegeta mustache one
battle in particular has gone down in
infamy not as the most insanely powerful
ridiculously destructive fight nor
as the most satisfying and well-written
story arc that has the longest
drawn out fight that's ever graced our
tv screens dare i say the longest fight
in the history of all of television
yes i am talking about the frieza saga
for those of you who are nodding your
heads or able to read a title now for
those of you who aren't familiar with
dbz the frieza saga refers to episodes
75 through 107 of the original dragon
ball z run
during this arc the z fighters go to the
planet namek in order to gather the
dragon balls which will allow them to
summon a dragon able to grant one wish
their goal is to revive all those who
died at the hands of the saiyans
several sagas ago frieza the main
antagonist of the saga
overhears talk about the namekian dragon
balls and sets out to the planet to wish
for immortality
the two groups eventually meet and since
this is dragon ball
they fight for a very long time to give
you an idea
they're on namek starting at episode 36
and the big bad of frieza
really doesn't do all that much until
episode 75 75
and here you thought my episodes were
full of filler but of all that filler
nothing is as infamous as this moment
five minutes
that's how long you have five minutes is
all that i need
now in most cases this would make it
seem like the planet should blow up in
i don't know five minutes you know on
account of the fact that he
just said that but this is dragon ball z
so five minutes through the magic of
anime is turned into
and i'm not exaggerating this at all two
hours 38 minutes and 55 seconds
give or take about a minute that is from
the end of episode 97
to the destruction of the planet in
episode 106.
so what all happens in that two and a
half hour span of time
well one hour and 18 minutes are spent
showing namek's destruction the events
on earth king kai's home
kami's lookout subplots with vegeta and
gohan that don't include frieza bulma
scenes and lastly reminiscing because
what better time is there to look back
at your past decisions
35 minutes are spent talking and this is
specifically anyone talking to frieza so
long as it's actively happening on the
battlefield
and finally 42 minutes are actually
spent throwing fisticuffs as well as
concentrated balls of energy now it
would be natural to assume that maybe
these fighters perceive
time differently and so that's why a
five-minute estimate balloons out to
nearly
three hours that the show has somehow
slowed down the fight so that we can see
it and comprehend it that it's all
cinematic timing this at least seems to
be the most popular theory as to what's
actually going on here the animating
staff animated the fight so that you
could understand what's happening
looking into the comments of these sorts
of videos they also seem to agree
except there's one problem the 35
minutes
spent talking to frieza sound can only
travel so fast
no matter what your power level is so
sure you can assume that literally
everything else in that three hour block
of time is happening concurrently or
happening at the speed of light but the
talking scenes prove
that at minimum the planet explodes no
less than 35 minutes after frieza's
original 5 minute prediction so then why
why would frieza say
5 minutes if namek clearly survives much
longer than that
that loyal theorists is what i'm here to
answer today personally i believe that
frieza didn't make a miscalculation
about the time at all
in fact i think he knew it would last
much longer the entire time
so let's hope your bodies can take it
because today we end the debate
once and for all i'm gonna start with
the simple facts if you do something a
lot no matter the task you get a good
feel for it and when it comes to blowing
up planets
frieza is a pro he knows what type of
planet how much power
and how much time it'll take for the
whole thing to go kaboom
look no further than planet vegeta which
he eliminates without breaking a sweat
so what was his issue with planet namek
why wasn't he able to destroy it as
easily as other planets
well first it was much denser than he
expected what do i mean by this well
have you ever noticed that namek has a
really long day cycle
like really really long as in every
single shot on namek is in the daytime
well because akira toriyama hated
drawing night scenes in the manga he
made namek
tidally locked this means its rotational
period matches its orbital period and i
guess
just to make sure that there would be
daylight super all the time namek is
locked not just with one
not just with two but with three suns
this is something that's actually
confirmed in the manga now typically
planets are ejected from these sorts of
tristar systems because they're just too
unstable to maintain the gravity of
three massive stars all
acting on the same ball of dirt would
normally pull a planet to shreds
ripping it in multiple different
directions but somehow namek is not only
able to stay in orbit but also stay
intact so how could that possibly be
well it means one of two things
either namek is ridiculously huge or
it's ridiculously dense now there's not
really a frame of reference for its size
but we do get one
indication that the world isn't
particularly big in the manga frieza's
henchman de doria says quote
without our scanners it's gonna be a
real pain tracking down these last two
dragon balls oh well
at least it's not too large of a planet
plus we see as the planet's collapsing
that gohan is able to travel back and
forth between the battlefield and the
capsule in a relatively short amount of
time but without seeing the effects of
frieza's planet destroyer
as such we can assume that the planet's
strength is coming not from its size but
rather its
density extending the time it takes for
the planet to blow up
and this surprises frieza he even makes
a comment after he fires his attack at
namek's core
stating that i have that too much power
this line isn't goku by the way he's not
even
facing him he says it to himself because
he knows immediately that it's gonna
take longer than he initially thought
and when goku calls him out on the next
line you see his attention audibly turn
you couldn't do it you couldn't go
through with it after all huh
so what do you do if you're frieza in
this moment you've miscalculated your
attack and you're on the ropes against a
really difficult opponent
well one thing that we've seen
throughout the various battles is that
frieza
is pretty darn smart he gets a lot
dumber as the series goes on but in this
main arc he's very strategic
serving as the polar opposite to goku
where goku fights on fair terms frieza
fights dirty where goku improvises
frieza strategizes interestingly enough
despite all the boasting and confidence
frieza is never one to assume things
will just work out take the destruction
of planet vegeta to prevent an uprising
in the loss of his throne he destroys an
entire planet purely based off the
legend of the super saiyan
in addition to militaristic
self-preservation and running an empire
448 planets deep frieza is
constantly using psychological warfare
against his opponents he seems to be a
follower of sun tzu's teachings because
you can actually trace most of his
tactics back to the art of war here's an
example from the book
rouse him and learned the principle of
his activity or inactivity
force him to reveal himself so as to
find out his vulnerable spots
for all the memes about it not being his
final form
frieza hides his true nature because of
this sun tzu quote a true fighter
doesn't reveal his true abilities until
he's fully sussed out his opponents
actually he does it quite a bit one of
frieza's signature characteristics is
that he often doesn't move a limb during
a fight while it could just be a result
of how sure of himself he is it also has
to be one of the other strategies in the
art of war
quote again be extremely subtle even to
the point of formlessness be extremely
mysterious even to the point of
soundlessness thereby you can be the
director of the opponent's fate by
not allowing his movements to be
predictable he is a total
wild card on the battlefield you can't
dodge or block what you can't see coming
and when your opponent isn't even moving
there's no way to prepare for a
counter-attack all of this plays into
frieza's psychological warfare
throughout the series we see instance
after instance of frieza belittling his
opponents
when fighting nail frieza praises his
power level of 42
000 only to cut it down by revealing his
own to be 530
000. building his confidence only to
break it down
completely crushing the genuine effort
nail had in powering up making the
soon-to-be struggle
all for naught and again these are all
lessons from the art of war quote
supreme excellence consists of breaking
the enemy's resistance without fighting
if your opponent is temperamental
seek to irritate him pretend to be weak
that he may grow arrogant if he's taking
his ease give him no rest a great
example of this is when gohan vegeta and
dende are forced to watch helplessly as
frieza literally plays with krillin
impaled on his horn
[Music]
by treating this powerful fighter like a
mere plaything frieza makes his raw
power and inhumanity seem that much more
unconquerable
striking fear into everyone watching
including vegeta himself
they're demoralized they've lost the
battle before it's really begun
because they're so afraid of their
opponent fast forward a bit and we can
see the same kind of twisted
demoralization tactics used during his
fight with piccolo
he intentionally humiliates and tortures
piccolo for the fun of it but
also to send a warning to everyone else
watching from below
that feeling of helplessness i was
hoping to inspire must be settling in
nicely
even in piccolo's final moments he lets
the namekian resurface
just so he can finish the job in front
of gohan because frieza has super
hearing he knows that piccolo means a
lot to the boy so he forces gohan to
watch his death
devastating gohan's morale during his
fight with goku
he's constantly bringing up how he's
killed so many people the namekians his
friends
specifically krillin all in an effort to
distract
and anger goku but it doesn't work the
two start fighting in episode 87 but 10
episodes later frieza's established that
he can't win by conventional means so
his most drastic offensive strategy is
to blow up the entire planet knowing
that goku will die
and he'll be okay in the vacuum of space
but when the planet doesn't completely
blow up like anticipated he has to come
up with a plan
to lie following another of sun tzu's
quotes all
warfare is based on deception in the
midst of chaos there is also
opportunity by the time frieza uses
destroy the planet he's figured the only
thing he has to do is force goku to rush
to screw up somewhere and look for an
opening to deliver the final blow
by setting the five minute timer frieza
intends to plant fear
and doubt into goku's head there's no
time to think you ever play chess using
a timer it's the same thing it forces
you to move faster and constantly be
thinking about the clock ticking down in
the background by frieza clearly letting
his opponent know that goku will die in
the explosion
while frieza survives whether it's true
or not it sets the stakes
super high for goku he has to finish the
job now to avenge his friends but the
clock is ticking
just like sun tzu said it created chaos
and there is
opportunity in chaos the fact of the
matter is that frieza without a doubt
use the whole
five-minute bit as a means of
psychological warfare to ensure goku's
defeat
the only problem was that he not only
underestimated the energy needed to
destroy the planet he also
underestimated goku himself but hey
that's just a theory a film theory
and goku begins turning the light bulb
next time on dragon ball z
you know i love the holiday season but
i'll be honest i miss the spoops surely
i'm not the only one with a
jack-o-lantern
hole in my heart right well my fellow
ghoul enthusiasts
ghoul enthusiasts we're in luck thanks
to our sponsor for today's episode
shutter as the world's premiere
streaming service for horror
thriller and supernatural content
shutter is spooky
24 7 365. that's right no more waiting
till october to raise your blood
pressure friends we're on the edge
all year long baby with shutter you get
access to the largest collection of
acclaimed horror movies and series
streamed right to your favorite devices
for just 5.99 a month you'll have
unlimited access to stream their unique
collection of exclusive and original
films
series and classics all ad-free with new
titles being added weekly now as head
theorist i watch
a lot of movies like a cornea frying
amount of movies so suffice it to say i
know good horror when i see it and let
me tell you i'm seeing it on shudder the
other night steph and i actually watched
host which is a shudder original about a
sans gone wrong that was shot entirely
over a zoom call and it was good yeah it
was good hands down one of the coolest
things i've seen this year i cannot
recommend host
enough and again it was a shutter
original to be honest horror is a genre
that's so often overlooked and it's so
nice to see a company funding brilliant
and talented filmmakers
making actual terrifying content so to
you shutter i say thank you and if you
want to say thank you to shutter 2
try it free for 30 days go to
shutter.com
that's shudder.com
and use the promo code film theory or
use the link down in the description
below that is shutter.com and then promo
code film theory for
30 days free use it if nothing else to
watch host
it is absolutely a movie worth your time
and in the meantime have a great holiday
and i'll see you all
next week